Or about the virtual reality setup that we have back there.
That disturbs me.
It did.
Doesn't disturb me that you know,
it's bad for you.
Anything like that.
It's so fun and it's so immersive and I know and I know where it's going.
I'm like it's going to keep getting better and better.
Just like it was 30 seconds to download a just a simple piece of paper filled
with text,
you know,
20 years ago,
20 years from now that is going to look like crayons.
Oh totally.
I mean,
but that is the,
the,
you got to put that thing on your own.
A freak out.
There's some archery games too.
Yeah,
it's a bunch of them.
It's pretty cool.
You actually have a,
it's called a haptic feedback.
So as you draw the bow back,
you actually feel like a vibration handling.
Yup.
And then you let go like that clunk,
Tesla suit Jesus Christ tests.
While it's not the same company,
they're just calling it that far.
As far as I know.
Fuck you.
Other company,
Tesla suit on failed and ces 2019 takes virtual reality to new heights.
Yeah.
They're going to have haptic feedback suits.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
There's like 68 sensors in there and you can,
it's supposed to feel like up to a grain,
I guess,
and put one rarely
cracks.
Those are going gonna put it right on their posts and they're just going to kind
shoot themselves.
Ooh.
Ooh,
You could've come home.
You'll,
your girls going to have a haptic feedback suit on and one of them artificial
machine guns.
It's going wreck reality.
Yeah.
Video of a girl doing it.
Uh,
does she gets shocked?
No,
but,
well,
it's,
there's a couple of different things.
This is just a test,
but she takes like a hard front kick to the chest here.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know how,
how it felt to her,
but okay.
Let's see.
Hard front kick to the chess hot explosion back here.
Actually,
I did it.
Okay.
Second round.
I'm kicking you guys nothing.
Oh,
okay.
Appreciate it.
Oh,
it's not that hard,
but I did feel it right here.
Hot Explosion.
Oh,
do I really want to try it?
Yes,
I do.
Well,
there's a boxing game that you can play.
It's really cool.
And uh,
the boxing game,
you,
you see this guy in front of you,
like a big three d cartoon really?
But really cool graphics.
And when he punches you,
the whole screen goes bright.
Look,
you got your Bell Rung.
Damn.
It makes you nervous.
Like when I'm,
when I'm sparring with him any,
he punches me.
I'm like,
oh Jesus got to get my hands up.
I got to shit.
It feels real and you get exhausted because you're moving around.
You're punching just,
it's harder believe it or not to punch air than it is to punch something.
Oh,
definitely.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because you get tired,
you get tired easier.
Yeah.
So you're throwing your hands of this thing and you know,
you're,
and then she goes down,
you're like,
ah.
And it gets back up and your feet hurt from moving around,
squeaking around on the floor on really interesting.
Yeah.
So there's for sure going to be a weird world for our kids when they get to be,
you know,
our age,
the world is going to be unrecognizable.
Yeah.
I feel like it's taken the edge off things too.
It has that,
it really takes the edge off things like you haven't actually done that.
Like you haven't actually climbed Everest,
but I sort of have,
I did it in a virtual reality game and it was entirely though not really low.
You know,
you didn't have,
your life wasn't that stake.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
I've been actually talking about this on stage that I'm worried about this.
I'm worried about people being able to have experiences that they didn't earn.
You know,
like if,
if someone,
if there's a virtual reality game where you,
you play it and all of a sudden you're in a,
a NASCAR and you're,
you know,
you're winning some gigantic race.
You're in the driver's seat and your mood shifting the gears and you mean feels
like you're like indiscernible from feeling like you're winning a race.
That's going to happen.
You're going to,
they're going to be able to do all these different things and it's gonna.
It's gonna make people more and more dependent on technology and weaker and
weaker and weaker.
That's how I feel too.
Yeah.
It's like,
um,
it's like gone to the gym and working out and getting all of these muscles,
but then moving away from any manual labor.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
And not,
I'm not saying don't be fit,
but I'm saying if you'll build their muscles,
fucking use them.
That is true.
There's a lot of guys that go to the gym and they'll work out hard for 45
minutes an hour to Jim,
but make them work a construction site,
character,
lumber,
all day.
There'll be fucking complaining and looking for the protein shakes and now
the real problem is going to be sex.
Yeah.
That's the real problem.
You gotta be able to put those things on and have sex with anybody you want.
Like anybody scarlet Johannson it's fucking weed started.
They already doing these things where they face swap with computers.
So they'd take beautiful actresses and they put their face on porn stars bodies.
And it's hard to tell men,
I mean it looks like a sex tape with a famous actress.
That's these debating.
It is disturbing because a Jaguar I go one,
I'm sure the rest.
So um,
there is,
now we mentioned that talks about it and it's probably the gay his thing that's
ever lived.
But I think the real worry is that,
not just like see it,
but do it like the going to be able to like the matrix,
you going to be able to put this on and you're going to be able to like this
haptic feedback suit that's just one step.
Eventually they're gonna figure out a way to make your body feel it and then
you're going to,
you're going to be able to have sex with people done.
Yeah.
Like anybody you want.
Like you're never going to have to be nice to people again because everybody's
going to fuck you.
You know,
not,
that's one of the,
what am I,
my point was kind of on stage.
Is that like one of the reasons why it's hard?
Like it's hard to have sex with people.
Like you have to plan it out.
I mean,
it's not that hard,
but it's,
you know,
you have to agree that you like each other,
you have to hope that she likes you and you like her or whatever,
and there's,
you develop your personality,
like to get people to like you more that way.
It's more likely be a nicer person.
You get rewarded for that and you realize,
oh,
it's nice to be a nice person and it actually makes you a nicer person.
Yeah.
If you don't have to do that in the future,
we're going to be able to dress in a certain why and Cape hygienic and be nice.
And then,
yeah,
everyone just turns into a fucking slob because they're gonna sleep with some
pretty actress any law.
Yeah.
And in that virtual reality,
they're going to look like Ryan Reynolds anyway.
You're going to have a full six pack and look beautiful.
And then other people get to meet you in there.
They're also going to be pretending you're going to have some disgusting human
beings,
and then in that world they're going to be perfect.
But then there'll be people like me that I'm like,
Nah,
I'm traditional.
Yeah.
I sleep with real,
real,
my wife.
Real humans.
Yeah.
Is that,
that's going to be old school.
That's going to be like riding a bike.
Like what are you doing?
What's he doing?
Walk everywhere.
Uh,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
Ideas.
Uh,
I posted a photo,
a video actually,
which is like 700 images stack together at Joshua tree.
I saw that.
Yeah.
And it's like the Milky Way,
Cruz and pos,
but then there's just the air traffic dude.
He's in sign and shits like constant.
I'm like,
anyone look at in this muscle already looked like the future,
you know,
look so futuristic already.
And I'm like,
well,
it sort of is maybe this like we're living in it now.
Here it is.